Talk about talking to you today is that you represent reason and well thought
out opinions and those two things are very rare.
Well thought out.
Opinions are way more rare in my opinion than what you usually get,
which you usually get as a conglomeration of opinions that seem to make sense
per peripherally or casually.
They have,
uh,
a veneer of logic to them and be like,
I'll go with that because I don't have the time because most people don't have
the time.
Well,
going back to Israel,
I know we're probably,
are we wrapping up?
No.
Going back to Israel for one second,
it's become like a pillar,
right?
It's like,
okay,
if you're on the left,
I believe in,
you know,
criminal justice reform,
like any number of things.
Oh,
and by the way,
Israel is bad.
Like it became one of those things that most people don't really think about.
Right?
Right.
And like,
I think it's really important to think about things issue by issue and not just
be like,
Yep,
signing up for this whole slew of policies and views on things when actually
some of those things don't go together at all.
Well one thing than the woke left you're not allowed to do is criticize the more
repressive aspects of Islam.
You're not allowed to,
you don't do it.
If you bring up anything becomes Islamophobic in even if it's homophobic
thought,
if the ideas are homophobic or if women have to wear restrictive clothing,
all any,
any of the things that are incredibly commonplace,
you are not allowed to criticize those because those fallen to a protected
category.
I remember when I first ran into this in college when,
um,
we were talking,
I was in a conversation with other feminists and I definitely consider myself a
feminist about female genital mutilation.
And I encountered for the first time a species that I've come to know well,
which is feminists who sorted defend female genital mutilation on the grounds of
cultural relativism.
Who are we to judge?
And I remember just like I did not get over the shock of that.
You shouldn't do.
I'm not,
that is fucking terrifying.
I mean,
that is,
look,
I'm a,
uh,
outspoken,
rabid critic of circumcision.
I think it's disgusting.
I think it's ridiculous.
It doesn't make any sense,
but at least your Dick still works.
The idea that someone tried to equate circumcision and female genital
mutilation,
a person on the left did when I talked about it recently.
Yeah,
some fucking asshole online.
I don't remember who it was,
but you know,
I didn't even,
I didn't even exchange.
I just,
I read it and I went there.
Their Vagina doesn't work the same way anymore.
Do you understand that you can't have an orgasm anymore?
Okay.
You're cutting off a woman's clutter is to not because of cleanliness or any
fucking weird logic that they're using today to try to justify circumcision.
Way Worse,
you'll,
you're,
you're doing it to try to eliminate pleasure because you don't want the woman to
leave.
It's the same reason why you want to cover up with some
crazy,
but why,
Barb,
how are we hearing the whim,
the leaders of the women's march talk about sad or no honor killings,
female genital mutilation,
forced marriage for,
for for girls,
children,
children.
No.
Instead they're talking about bds in Israel.
I don't get it.
I'd love to ask someone about that.